Usually women that want to push
this and men who are bitches,
it's like these,
these men that don't like,
they don't like aggressive man. They
don't like manly men. And so they,
they push it as well.
It's because they're aggressive and
they're controlling and they want to run
shit.
And that's cause that's the thing where
like if you really look at their agenda
when they say the future is feminine,
that's not inclusive and they're,
and they're all about, I'll make
this more inclusive. It's like no,
let us in so we can take it over
and then we'll push you down. Is,
is the psychology of the kind
of person that goes after that?
Someone that's after like power, I'm not
saying the average woman is like that.
My wife is a feminist and she's
in delight conclusive shit.
But like people who
are spearheading stuff,
like those people are wired the same way.
Like you know,
I mean a dominator is yes,
yes.
And there's going to be no room for you.
It's going to be like think the way,
like a lot of that that's
so called progressives.
Extreme left is think the way we think.
Save what we say or we
will fucking destroy you.
Pull up that tweet that I retweeted today.
The David Pakman retweet.
David Pacman's is liberal progressive guy.
This woman posts on Twitter,
she would never vote for a man or a white,
a white man or a white
person, white, white,
someone who's white or male,
he says that's racist and sexist.
It is.
So she blocks him on Twitter today.
She called Boston College demanding
that they not have him back as adjunct
faculty.
It's crazy.
So this woman post this and he points
out that it's racist and sexist.
So she blocked him and she
tries to get him fired. Okay.
This is why that whole thing is fucked up.
Okay.
Because he's acting like white people
exist on an even plane, which is,
which a lot of people try to do.
So it's like he's not necessarily,
he's just saying that what she's
saying is racist and sexist. Yes.
Cause she's determining who she's going
to vote for based and tire on the race.
But there's other elements involved,
like the level that white people,
not saying all white people,
but white people have fucked
over people who are not white.
Forget about poor white people who they
fucked over. So you understand that.
But he,
they're both right.
But then like the fact that she then
takes it to the point that because he had
the audacity to have a
difference of an opinion,
that that's the thing now and that now
we're going to destroy you and you can't
be on this thing.
And then the other level of that is how
the corporate entities are cell afraid
that one fucking nickel is going to roll
out the dough because all of this shit
is,
you're just a paper tiger and till you
get the big behemoth to listen to you and
this,
all of these,
these fucking things from award shows
to this bullshit that someone just needs
to be like, listen, this guy
already apologize. This is,
this is an old fucking
thing. Or, uh, look,
you just had a difference of opinion that,
you know,
this isn't the first time you're going
to say something and somebody's going to
disagree with you. That doesn't,
that this guy can't come back. Um,
you know,
and you obviously,
cause it's some shit that's happened to
you have an extreme opinion about this
guy because of the color of his skin.
It's like there's so many
fucked up elements to that that,
but for some reason you can't, like
if you address that on any level, um,
then you're part of the problem and then
not just part of the problem that she's
trying to get him fired.
She's trying to get him fired for
pointing out that something is racist on
saying if you say what I just says,
tried to look at it three 60. Oh yeah.
As much as I can, which is why I love
South Park is everything that they do,
they do it three 16. Right. And, uh,
so I learned a lot from
that show by the way.
They look at stuff like that because
I don't fucking know everything.
But even just to try and be like,
well hey, you know, you know,
we salted them a little bit. I understand
what you're saying and blah, blah blah.
You can't fucking do that anymore.
Cause then somebody your part
of the fucking problem and no,
it's really getting crazy.
It got to the point like I've seen,
I'm not gonna name names,
but I've seen like, you know,
a tweet from a fellow comic telling
comics what jokes you shouldn't talk about
this topic.
It's like who the fuck are you?
And it's like there's already
been enough people doing that.
You're going to do like cannibalism.
Now.
Have you really, you've ever
seen comics say that real comics?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean everybody has their
opinion on somebody fucking
act. But I mean, yeah. Yeah.
That's ridiculous. That's
not a real comic. Um,
well I wouldn't say that
they are real comic.
They just have an opinion I don't agree
with. They can fuck off. Oh, I mean, yeah.
I mean
trying to have less confrontations.
I have sin in my life here.
That kind of shit drives me crazy though.
What drives me most crazy
is this bullying. What she's
trying to get him fired.
Just try to get him fired for having an
opinion on something that she publicly
stated.
One of these,
the, somebody running one of these
things has to be like, you know,
and it can't just be private.
It has to be a public
tweet to say that this is,
it's just going too far in this fucking
thing where you have a difference of an
opinion now and they're just going to,
you know,
take your fucking job away. You
know, I ran into this shit, you know,
when, you know, when the me too
stuff first started coming out,
people would try to
like, you know, you know,
you had to tweet the right
fucking thing and if,
and if you said anything sort of,
oh, it's, let's look at the evidence.
God forbid you fucking said that. And
it just became like this whole, uh,
your part of the problem.
Then they would try to take you down
[inaudible]
someone you were,
you were friends with or doing a
show with a represented by they,
they would try to do like
that pressure to try in a,
and it was just like in all he had to
say, I was like, no, I'm not doing that.
And then it just goes away because you
don't have to fucking leg to stand on.
Well also the people that are doing it,
it's a small percentage of a,
it's a very lean, small,
unbelievably small and the,
and you know comics,
it's like we're literally running
for office out there campaigning
for this election that never happens
and you're going through red states,
blue states,
you going through fucking everything.
And the general consensus of people is
like, like, dude, that was fucking crazy.
Like that.
That doesn't make sense.
But no one wants to say it because
they're going to get steamrolled.
So I would have an a Matt Damon,
right?
Matt Damon said we have
to make a differentiation
between the Harvey Weinstein's
in the world. And then someone
who, you know, like Aziz Ansari,
he goes on a bad date. There's a
big difference between those two.
And they attacked him and they tried
to get them pulled off of that movie
ocean's eight.
Yeah.
And they were acting like that,
like killing somebody versus
stealing your car versus Jay walking.
Like literally the whole judicial
system is based on what you did is your
punishment. Your parents do that.
Right. You know what I mean?
You're bad was what you did. Yeah. Yeah.
That's all. That's what that sounded like.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
We live in a world now.
I have to be measured in the way
that I say that what he said,
you know,
affected me how I heard it.
And then all of a sudden this is just a
terrible fucking bald white male. Yup.
And they did they go in that route.
It's like you,
you literally sound like what
the fuck you're against. And um,
it's, it's a, a, it's not going
to last. And I feel like a,
it's like the end of the winter and
people want to go outside and get some sun
on their face and you didn't
like, no, no. Like uh,
taking people by the back of their fucking
neck and fucking shoving their face
in the shit that you can't sustain
that. No, you can't sustain.
It doesn't work. You don't get
people to change by yelling at them.
It doesn't work.
Or You just bombing them like what
the fuck we're doing with like deck?
That's not all you're doing is you're
just building up resentment and more
people want to fucking take you down.
So that's like a
don't understand psychology.
So what they think is this is their time.
This is their time to get back at.
Men does their time to yell at men.
This is the time to where the
future is feminine tee shirts.
This is a time to take their stand.
And then what did you not see?
The women's March?
I saw a bunch of people walking,
right?
Listen,
I'm not saying the points that
they're making don't need to be made.
I'm not saying that their
complaints are not just, it's,
it's the execution of it.
Yes.
Where it's like you're going to go through
intimidation and destroying people,
like exactly. People's careers and
people you have to publicly apologize.
It's so, it's like it's
bullying people. Yes.
Some of the biggest bullies right now,
I can't believe it because I'm a lefty
are on my side of the fucking fence and
you know when someone's on your side of
the fence and you're looking at him like
you sound like a fucking crazy person.
That's when you've entered like, you know,
what was your special strange
times? Weird. Yeah. Like it's like,
it is strange. Yeah. It is
strange because it's, it's,
they feel like they're justified because
they feel like with a maniac like Trump
in the office, that they have to do what
they have to do to change the world.
But you don't change the world by yelling
at people. It doesn't work that way.
And there's this real points to
be made is real points about,
I couldn't imagine being a woman working
in an office with a bunch of guys
trying to fuck you all the time.
It's got to be a God damn nightmare.
I can't imagine having a bunch of
bosses that literally tell you,
you suck my Dick, I'll give
you a race that happens. Yes.
Fucking it's gotta be hell.
I get it. I mean, I get it.
You gotta be like an eight til eight on
up to deal with that every day. I mean,
let's be fucking honest. You
know what I mean? There's really,
there's really six is out
there. It's really good. If
you've got a person to him,
a lot got a nice ass,
just say it. You know, it's
just like, some of that shit
is like fucking, you know,
it's, it's, I always viewed it like,
like you ever watch like the behind the
scenes of like a prison and the first
thing every guy thinks is like, how the
fuck would I not getting raped in there?
Right, exactly. Women have
to think that just, yeah,
fucking walking down the street. So that's
how I wrap my head around to be like,
wow, okay. Like what they're
saying is like, cause I don't like,
like, uh, like a lot of the arguments
then, and I like that doesn't make sense.
It's what doesn't make sense to me is
the children of the corn fucking torches
burning and just go like,
um,
the way that, I mean it looks, a lot of
people don't, they do that with like, uh,
our foreign policy.
Like this whole fucking
thing is bankrupted this
country every August now they
just shut down the government, which has
just become normal and all they do to,
to make it like,
okay,
is they just raised the level of debt
that we legally can take on or whatever.
And it's like, all right,
let's do this for another year.
And if you question any of that,
that means you don't support the troops
and you're a fucking piece of shit.
He need to get the fuck outta here.
And it's like so much stuff
doesn't make sense to me. Like,
I just saw Michelle Obama,
they had this fucking tweet of her
wearing these glitter thigh high boots and
said sets Twitter on fire with
their $4,000 fucking boots.
And it's just like,
you know,
do you don't question
where she got that money.
The president makes 500 grand a year.
She blew four grand and thigh high boots
and don't even talk to me about the
fucking book deal and all of that shit.
That fucking guy his first like to,
you know,
public speaking engagement things where
like with major banks and you go out on
the road, thousands of dollars
and all these guys are like,
fucking all these fellow Americans are
upside down in the house from those
fucking bank accounts who did not get,
did not get punished in
2008 they all shoot me.
We'll talk about like people who should
have their fucking lives burned down.
Those people and these guys they're in,
they have their faces in
the same fucking pig trough.
It's the guys with the red
ties and for whatever reason,
like I don't, and I don't know
why. Like they get a pass.
Exactly. It doesn't make any sense. More
serious shit. Like drone strikes, more,
more innocent civilians were killed
with drone strikes during Obama's
administration.
I know.
And that's why they're telling me you
fight and terrorism while you're creating
more of it because all I would want to
do is just get revenge. Exactly. And uh,
you know, I have very simplistic ways
of how to get the fuck out of there.
How do you do it? Well, I mean,
I'm not saying the air would be
cleaner cause I don't know what,
like when you throw a Tesla battery into
the fucking ocean, what that does to it.
I'm sure it's fucking horrible,
but I know that there are a one stop shop
over there in the Middle East and they
got oil and that's it.
You know,
I always compare them member that kiosk
in like the South Shore Plaza in Boston,
there was a something,
it was a place called Wickson sticks.
All they did was sell candles,
which just seemed like a really
vulnerable business or pewter pot.
The first they just sold muffins and
then they started doing full breakfast as
well. They'd like a pewter
pot that just selling muffins.
So if we stopped buying muffins
and we got enough oil here,
if we switched to solar power and all that
shit and hell, the windmills are ugly.
And I know it's probably just as
much fucking bad on the environment.
But what it does is it gets you out of
there and it bankrupts them and then they
don't have the money to funnel through
the mosque to, to, to fund the terrorists.
Well, the United States is exporting
oil now, which is crazy. I mean, we, we,
we have a lot of oil. Right. And
especially through, you know,
frankly, I'm just saying if
you ever suggested that. Yeah.
Which I think I just did,
I think then for some reason I don't
love my country and like I'm trying to
solve it. I'm a frugal guy, you
know, I don't fucking, you know,
I don't spend beyond my
means. And you know, uh,
I don't like debt and that type of shit.
I don't know how the fuck these guys.
I think that's why the
president age is so much.
Um, well didn't get enough sleep. The
pressure you mentioned the dead bodies,
everything, all of that. Oh, a bitch
is knowing how everything really works.
Oh yeah. Trump doesn't seem to mind.
He just takes the extra Adderall.
It keeps on trucking. He doesn't,
seems like he's all the scandals.
That guy seems complete cause I think he,
he's,
he's a certain level sick
mentally that it does.
It does.
It doesn't get in. I mean,
because he hasn't aged at all.
Now granted he's got all that white
stuff around his eyes and he, you know,
I don't know what he's
doing with the hair,
but the hair is usually the telltale sign.
Yeah. Yeah. He's one of the
only presidents that, you know,
it's like half of that
shit's probably from a doll.
Like who knows where that has got enough
money to do like a transplant at this
point. Right. You can't do a transplant
on that thing. He doesn't have any,
he doesn't have any donor area. What do
you mean he's got it all in the back?
Doesn't know. He doesn't ever see what
happens when it flies up in the back.
When the wind hits it,
the back's all bald.
All because he probably did the
original plugs and they didn't take,
who knows what he's got going on back
there. He's got chaos going on back there.
You ever seen it? Yeah. I mean he's, the
president hits it and his hair flops up,
but you ever seen the video of him?
It looks like he's a guy
wearing a demon demon mask.
It's very wispy,
wispy,
like it's missing look like
look like a baby would be nuts.
If he gets a second term
and he shaves his head,
that would be nuts and he would just look
like the most evil fucking dude ever.
Like that would be like if
you've got a second term shaves,
his head starts doing intermittent
fasting. Lifting weights gets on steroids,
drops down about a buck 90 jacked.
Yeah, I mean that would
be, I think a, yeah,
it's definitely a,
I don't,
that's why I'm trying to just
in my own little fucking world,
I'm trying to chill out more and
I'm trying not to fucking, uh,
there's just, there's enough yelling. I
don't think that they need it from me now.
Let's think more mocking and
laughing then yelling for sure.
But when you see enough of those,
the future is feminine tee shirts and
you see enough hypocrisy and you see
enough people trying to take people
out for commenting on what's sexist and
racist and trying to get people fired.
Like it's a time of outrage across the
board and you have to respond a little
bit. You have to let people know, hey,
this is fucking ridiculous. Like there's,
there's a certain obligation,
especially comedians have
as a social commentator.
You see some stupid shit if
you're not commenting on it.
If you choose to go that route.
And some people just like,
I'm just going to let you forget your
whole work week and I'm just in talk about
a bunch of shit,
small stuff.